えっ
e 4
me
えっ
んどいかもよようやく新しい案に映って1わけなんですけれども
見ての通りレーダーの湯です
もうちょっと違うのはこう言う
2回がないんですよ太らなくてこういうベッドになったのと全然前が部屋とは違います
そしてちょっと白いですあとなんでレオパレスにしたかというと思うんですけれども
家具が付いてくるんですよ事実だって新生活するときに電子レンジとか冷蔵庫とか
インターネットの回線とか洗濯機とかたぶんで守護イスか全製品を買うだけで祝賀に
変わるんですけど
全部付いてるんで本当にそのまま
映っても大丈夫なレベルなんで日常雑貨を買ってきたんですけど本当イライラするん
ですよ
ものが多すぎるだと今チャリしかないんでもうさっき入ってきたみたいな格好でも
チャリで
もうドンキまで行ってめっちゃもなかって
でこんなのって言ったらそれはもうのあるいやもうマジ基地みたいな目で見ますよ
なんで今日はね
あんまりこう
ちょっと村にちなんでこうまだ落ち着いていきたいんですけどちょっと買ったものを
紹介しようと思いますというものを買ったものを一列にしたんで
ちょっと見てってください本当にこれは今日今日買ったものなんでもう間違いないです
ね
あちなみにあの新しい形態は聚楽 cs 4にさせていただきました
ケースがもうかっこいいから早急っていう感じですよねピゲソリの刃だけ買いました後
ゼロです後はジョイですね皿を洗うときに使います
あとは oi ます
ボディタオルんですねあとは是澤です
長い竿を大また飲みさせのコーラと
wi-fi ルーターですこれは
wi-fi ルーターです rooters ねーなーバター部です
ん
トイレクリーナーと培土入った選択もなるとき
あとは固定ですとフライパンと
パブリーズタップ投入
トイレを払う奴
えっとトイレのマットと
アド風呂のマットと
ティッシュと
ゴリラマットとイヤホンです一人暮らしとか始めるときには
か電化月期の家を選んだ方がとても
こっちの方が楽になると思いますやっぱセンターきっとはからだけでもかさばるんで
この会社ってわけじゃないんですけど嘉年華月期の良いは本当におすすめなんでぜひ
一人暮らし考えている方はそういうところも
見た方がいいと思います
ちょっと真面目な子といけません目標ねっ
あ
一応サブチャンネルねー
部屋の様子を撮ったのだしたんでぜひそれぞれ寝る
動画の下の説明欄にあるんでぜひ見てってください
ねちょっとソニチで疲れちゃっててあ
まずはこう慣れていくことが初めてん
昔の怠惰な生活に戻れるように頑張りたいと思います
じゃあなー
んの
[音楽]
ん